>> My name is Orly Halpern. I'm a journalist
based in Jerusalem and I'm now at the World
Economic Forum on the Middle East in Jordan
and I've been asked if I think role models
are important and my answer is an absolute
yes. I think we all agree on that. What I
see is the question is not who are the role
models and I as an Isreali, Jewish, and American
citizen living in Israel feel that we lack
role models for peace. A lot of people that
talk peace, they say they want peace, but
the things that they are supporting are not
really going to bring about that peace and
that's a problem. So then you have people
that follow them that think well my leaders
want peace, they say they want peace, I want
peace so if they think it's okay to build
more settlements, that will bring peace, they're
going to follow those people but we're not
going to get peace. And I'm concerned that
we don't have role models that will truly
bring peace to the region and end the Palestinian/Israeli
conflict in a peaceful way.